hot breath do you think those are still
worth it the zoom shows
absolutely yeah because they teach you
another level
they teach you to relate to this thing
right there right
and it's like you this is that's unusual
but how does that impact you now if you
get an agent you start doing commercials
and now you have no problem talking to
the camera like i'm talking to you guys
like i'm looking in your eyes
right but it's so weird because in
comedy we don't look in everybody's eyes
at the exact same time so it's a little
different but you can
you can actually use it and ponder and
do that sort of thing you can use your
your framing to go you know it's like uh
you know it's like and i can't do this
and
you know it's like i can't do anything
because i'm jewish i can't
you know i can't uh i can't watch
stranger things on the sabbath i can't
do this
and it's like i can't covet my
neighbor's wife and she's hot
you know always coming over what another
cup of sugar
so you can do that and use the frame
to create the joke so if you're
imagining what's
what's what they're seeing in the frame
you can utilize that to your advantage
and they force you to be more creative
now so
but you see how that you're seeing it in
a different perspective
too now they could see your eyes now you
can do facials now you can do things
with your eyebrows that maybe you didn't
do before
right you know you used to do a true and
false quiz in class you know
my friend and i would send signals he'd
study one night i'd study it the next
night would split the work
in half next day he'd be looking at the
at the question he'd go
all right that was true you'd send the
signals that one's false
he has no idea you know so now you have
now you could do that where they
wouldn't be able to see you up on the
stage in the back from the back of the
room so
there's those advantages also watch john
john oliver watch how he when he first
started after the pandemic
doing the show's sort of remotely and
how it evolved
and he's just like wow he doesn't even
stop for the laugh
it's just it happens by accident
and it's so riveting that's why he won
another emmy
you know because that's something to
to take from if you see so if you join
these gyms
zoom shows see what other people are
doing steal the moves that are working
if the oh that guy gave a look like that
that seemed to really get a lap oh i can
use facial expressions
i can do a deadpan i go you know and she
wants me to come over
get into use that camera to your uh to
your affected
shift a dynamic level in your act you
know
it's like you know and this is all going
on of course
during the pandemic you know or
during the apocalypse you know that
gives it a conspiratorial
type of thing you know use that camera
as you're leaning in and trying to
whisper to them
so that's a that this this zoom thing
provides
other creative opportunities you know
all crisis leads to some sort of
opportunity
you